good evening thanks for being here at
six i'm denise feltes parents and
teachers are protesting in henderson
tonight to push back against a decision
to return to distance learning i'm
kirsten joyce lamping elementary
transitioned back to online this week
citing a high number of coven 19 cases
on campus sasha loftis joins us live
with more on their message sasha
denise and kirsten this protest has been
happening for about an hour it is
starting to slowly wind down now but
there are still some parents teachers
and students out there making their
message clear now they were had signs as
you can see in chance earlier this
evening again protesting lamping
elementary here in henderson
transitioning to distance learning
earlier this week citing that high
number of covet 19 case numbers on
campus now those here today are
protesting that decision and want their
kids to continue learning in person
they're also claiming the school and the
district are not being transparent about
the number of cases present here a quick
check of the ccsd covet 19 dashboard
says as of yesterday the school does not
have any positive cases but the district
has said to eight news now the
information is updated regularly but not
in real time to allow for verification
now again clark county school district
returned to in-person learning earlier
this month the principal here has said
that after that evaluation that they
should be able to return to in-person
learning here on august 30th reporting
live in henderson tonight sasha loftis 8
news now